[Music]
hello and welcome to the greatest movie
ever podcast where every month we
dissect our guest favorite film in all
its silver screen cinematic scope this
week I'm joined by a very good friend of
mine I love this guy's knowledge on
anime movie and pop culture in general
every time I speak to him he's got the
lowdown on some new movie or TV show and
a lot of the things he tells me you've
helped a lot to add insight to my videos
and his girlfriend also runs the social
media accounts for MTV The Huffington
Post and several reputable media
services and he's always got one foot in
the news in media so with great pleasure
I welcome you Callum how we do mate yeah
I'm not too bad I'm not too bad yet no
really good thank you
and so today we're gonna be discussing
alien and which I was really excited
about because it's one of my favorite
films as well do you remember the first
time that you saw it mm nah it was quite
a while ago the first time sorry but I
definitely I watched them all at the
same time so I one two three four all
right I just remember that that that
intense love like the fear of unknown so
it was like it was such a different
concept when I watching this film cuz I
hadn't watched anything like that before
so did you like all four of them or do
you have like your favorites
aliens number two yeah he's my favorite
definitely and number one was probably
like second to that yeah and that's
mainly because number two is slay such a
different film every time you watch it
yeah definitely and the number one is
sort of like more just scary three and
four is there's still good look I
normally you know I'm against a point
where like when you think of something
that happened in them it's like I did
the happening three or did that
happening for whereas like number two
and one
we stand out a lot more for me yeah and
I definitely agree I think I was about
four
when I saw a lien because my granddad
knew I liked aliens and it recorded it
off TV thinking that I'll have fun with
it
I just I just remember being terrified
by it and it definitely stuck with me
especially that strap line I mean
there's been so many parodies on in
space no one can hear you scream it's
had such a huge legacy I've seen it
obviously copied its aesthetic copied in
films such as event horizon life and
even the Cloverfield paradox quite
recently but none have really come close
to it um and it's strange because this
film was never actually like positively
that the studio weren't that excited
about making it it only actually got
greenlit because of Star Wars New Hope
was like a massive success and Fox
wanted to kind of capitalize on on the
basically ride the coattails of Star
Wars and the only script that they had
at the time involving space was alien
and so that that's why I got made which
is quite interesting yeah that's pretty
interesting sort of like writing the
whole space team yeah I think a lot of
movies did back then like Moonraker
definitely did and there was just a lot
of films getting released purely because
Star Wars was so popular and it's sort
of like comic book movies now where
because Marvel and DC are so popular
that pretty much everything gets
greenlit if it's based on a comic book
and what was it about this movie that's
kind of stuck with you so long hmm it's
a good question um I think I think as
far as alien goes the first one the
thing that stuck the sticks with me
every single time by the first thing I
think about what I think about this film
is the scene where you first see the
chest burster yeah and I think that's
pretty much pretty much it should be the
same for everyone else I think um and
just because as far as my where I'm
pretty sure that that scene wasn't
scripted yeah
they they had a brief idea of what was
going to happen but Scott going to keep
them in the dark about it to get yes
jumps on the table like all them
reactions are so like organic yes it is
just with him things where like I'm
there I was there sad the table even my
food and like some guy is just freaking
out on the table and I think that's the
bit that sticks with me like the most I
think going on from that I'm like every
time you watch it you just sort of see
you can see you like the way that like
Sigourney Weaver likes of changes like
your other yeah where it goes from hey
you know captain or whatever and then
all the sitting is you know this females
are like badass yeah what he thinks was
great so controversially this movie
actually has two versions and it's got a
director's cutting a theatrical cut
Ridley Scott has actually went on record
saying that he prefers that the out
record cut but they had to offer
something new for the the re-releases in
the Nori's there's only about two
minutes of extra footage so it isn't
that different do you prefer the
director's cut all jujube are you more
kind of Orthodox and prefer the original
over hmm you know what I think because
so when I was younger I would have had
the DVD of it yeah like the box set with
the egg on the front yeah and I'm pretty
sure that was the director's cut yeah
pretty much watching it grow you know I
probably only ever saw
the directors good okay so yeah I don't
think you're honest I couldn't even tell
you what the two minutes were in the
original so the extra minutes are when
and the guys get it
he gets goes after the cat and he gets
attacked by the alien this oh yeah
lightly different shots they're they're
not massively noticeable but I basically
only know it's because I remember the
scene being a certain way because I've
watched it so many times and then when I
rewatched I was thinking hold on that
looks a bit different
and towards the end
Ripley sort of stumbles into the alien
nest
and sees a lot of her teammates kind of
strung up on the walls and it's it's
very much more sort of ties into aliens
rather than just alien on its own I
actually prefer just the original I mean
what's the the other one does kind of
tie in with the alien queen in the
sequels I think it's just so bad that we
don't know what happened to the crew it
kind of makes it more horrifying
thinking that they just got dragged off
all the time they say there's no blood
and when they go looking for the body so
I do kind of prefer that um but yeah I
mean it's it's very little differences
it's not like a Batman V Superman where
you've got an extra half an hour in
there or even alien 3 what has such a
differing director's cut to the original
one yeah well I do know aliens 2 has
things like 18 minutes
yeah cow of it and and the scenes that
the good cow of aliens is quite I feel
like they're quite important yes yeah I
definitely thought that he left like the
original left a lot out compared to the
directors go yellow and Cameron did that
with Terminator 2 as well if you've ever
watched the Ultimate Edition of that
there's quite a lot of extra material is
even a different ending for the film so
it's really strange that Cameron sort of
used to limit his movies back then so
back to this one the way the movie opens
I remember even as a kid the kind of
long and drawn-out hypnotic title screen
just kind of drew me in it's it's so
eerie and scary and there's just sort of
something about it it's like 2001 a
Space Odyssey but with an element of
horror and I think personally even
though the movies like from the 70s all
of the Speights shots still hold up they
sort of have an industrial and rundown
feel of them which makes them brilliant
a watch
do you remember sort of do you like the
long drawn-out opening or you kind of
more just get into the action of it I
think I think I think the long drawn-out
open is it's not it's not like a staple
for that sort of like series of films I
think
it's one of them things that when you
first see it I don't know I don't know
why but it almost fills you with like a
sense of dread yeah definitely and it's
just that sort of I think I think it it
automatically starts building tension
when you don't even realize it it starts
building tension cuz it's already like
how what's gonna happen ex what's gonna
happen next and you know that draw now
feeling and I think I think the I think
the same thing happens in aliens and
obviously coming back to what you said
about Star Wars they're they also follow
a similar thing we know at the spaceship
flying over yes what's wrong now so I
think it's certainly sort of implies
just how alone
they are like space is so desolate and
cold and empty in you sort of get the
feeling if something does go wrong out
there that there's gonna be no help
coming to them and which is great now
one of the main themes of the film is
that of a womb I would have been
watching quite a few analysis of the
film and the best example of this is
that the crew sort of sleep in a room
that has a sort of whoom feeling to it
mmm especially with the cryo pods and
stuff yeah exactly they sort of wake up
like babies and in the middle of a
nightmare
I mean smother rings mentioned in the
movie and throughout this kind of an
organic look to the alien and the ship
that sort of mimics female genitalia
especially in the look of the facehugger
the obviously eggs plastered throughout
when Ripley's getting attacked by ashes
actually porn pictures against the wall
um and right next to them there's some
eggs as well so there's these very
subtle tie-ins together also the main
computer is called mother and so there's
sort of a repetition of a very female
centric aspects and Scott even refers to
the mother room as the womb room and
encountering this is also a lot of
phallic symbols such as the aliens head
yeah I think a lot of that comes from
like hitchhikers original song yes
drawings and yeah and it's just like
once you're looking out for sort of
phallic things they're very easy to know
it's like the chest bursts
mm-hmm and even the pencil that's used
to get acid it kind of looks like a dick
watch it again and you'll be like yeah
it does look a bit like a dick I don't
know if I'm to myself yeah so ash shoves
a magazine down at least throw as he
tries to kill her
which could also be like sort of I don't
know quite it's rape like themed mmm
I mean there's nothing that massively
really different shades it but you know
that there's some little themes in there
and obviously the the birth of the alien
is a huge thing so it kind of turns back
into this life cycle yeah and it's just
obvious that Ridley Scott kind of had
these themes in um but skipping all the
talk of dick in that what do you think
of Ripley as a main character yeah I
think I think I think Sigourney Weaver
has done like a brilliant job and I
think I think he also translates to
quite a lot of films even like now yeah
so he's always playing at least yeah
yeah exactly I don't think it's a bad
thing because if she can definitely
differentiate between characters but
it's sort of painted or with this you
know I am you know like I'm not gonna be
[ __ ] with type your attitude and I
think it plays off really well and being
able to see Rick Lee grow like with wave
of the films is I think yeah I think
it's awesome
yeah it's great and I love how like
whilst the final girl sort of motif has
become a bit of a cliche this was the
first film to really do it there's this
sort of a masculinity to her like almost
a silent power that you can sort of see
deep within I mean it's very subtle
she's not a damsel in distress and she
sort of tackles their problems straight
on you know and an interesting thing
about the script is that if you look at
the characters names they're all
actually unisex and because Scott kind
of wanted to do blind casting
and he had a lot of free rein over
choosing Ripley he didn't want to sort
of have it nailed in straight away that
it was definitely gonna be a girl so
there is sort of a fluidity almost her
gender portrayal I love the way that she
gives [ __ ] back to the rest of the crew
and she's not really a yes-man she
follows protocol and she won't let the
crew back in on the ship when the alien
has attacked Kane she's like she's down
and let them die for the safety of the
crew yeah and she also doesn't turn she
doesn't trust ash which turns that would
be justified she's like really really
headstrong and definitely aliens of
course we're going to build upon this
and there's a I would say there's a
bigger transformation in that she goes
kind of from the fearful yeah agura
fraid of her own shadow having
nightmares to tackling them straight on
in and saving Newt so I think it is just
a brilliant main character especially
for a horror movie that you can really
get behind and what do you think what do
you think about the other characters
I think what's the actor's name there
any in home yeah I thought that was
really good and that was such a good
like you know when the head and then ice
and Android yeah thing and I was I think
I think Kane also as we could that was a
Jean her I think yes yeah which is also
awesome
yeah I think I think I think that the
casting the first one is good I
definitely think that we got the casting
better in the second one yeah yeah yeah
I really agree with the Android twist
and I think with the rest of the crew as
well as a sort of authenticity to them I
really like how they focus on Dallas um
and you the first time you watch this
you could think are he's the main
character but he's gets taken out in the
midsection and to me that's a really
like great way
of elevating the threat of the alien
when they take out your main character
it's like oh [ __ ] this is like a proper
threat and the vent scene is just
brilliant layer really gets my heart
racing yeah and it's sort of interesting
to know that Scott wrote full
backstories for each character and I
think that's why they're so believable
in this film like they're trying to do
in Alien Covenant um but to me it was
just kind of a mimic of this film and I
think they do a much better job of
portraying real people like horror
movies often are kind of guilty of their
characters being sort of very
one-dimensional and you just want to see
them killed off where is this
you kind of want everyone to survive
almost yeah yeah that well and if not
survive at least at least at least a try
and I'll skip but at least fight back to
the alien wiki ends of proving hopeless
as it is yeah definitely yeah I'm just
going back a bit I I love when they
explore the alien ship on lv-426
I mean it's so slow paced and mysterious
and then the big jump scare comes out at
the end it just builds tension for ages
and massively delivers on it it's it's
sort of the exploration that you would
take if you visit it a new planet it's
very sort of hesitant um it's not like
covenant where they just sort of rush
out and all take their masks off and run
about the place mmm and it sort of leads
into hinting at Prometheus and alien
covenant what do you think of those
movies - you prefer them I don't know
why I said you prefer them I'm not sure
on the current sort of like whoa you
know the general consensus of
Prometheus's yeah but I actually did
quite enjoy premiere okay alien covenant
I was a bit 50/50 on it but the made the
main thing is why I like Prometheus is
that I'm a complete sucker for the
backstory okay and more like you know
where's it come from like why is the
alien an alien you know
that type of thing yeah so and even even
though there was a few bits and pieces
in there whereas like okay I get it but
you know it's not great I think it was
more just the concept of like the
backstory would you like the most which
I mean I guess some people might agree
on and there are some people just paid
it and just you know never watch again
yeah I kind of wish that they never made
them I am just someone who prefers
mystery in films and I think those
prequels kind of Rob the ambiguity that
makes the ship so enthralling especially
like they're engineers carcass I
remember that sort of they ended shot on
just zooming in on him very very slowly
and it just kind of has an atmosphere to
it and it's very creepy you kind of
thinking well what's done all this and
Tyler answered I mean the yeah it just
kind of takes away their to me horror
movie monsters are best when you know
very little about them and that's really
interesting because I'm like the
complete opposite yeah that's really
interesting even even with some of the
more classic horror films like you know
you know you've got you cheers and you
Freddie yeah all that same stuff like
you know drawing it out for 12 films
obviously you know can be a bit
laborious but you know just a little bit
so oh it was you know his mum or it was
his sister's is you know oh yeah by them
little bits later to make me want to
watch the phone just so I can get a
little bit a second piece like an entire
backstory to these like mysterious
characters okay that's fair enough but
you're wrong I'm gonna edit all that out
so the chestburster scene it's kind of
aged a bit and I know to me it's the
weakest part of the movie effects wise
and it's a shame because you can see the
suit stuff like underneath it but it
does still have impact to it like you
saw how horrifying this facehugger was
strapped around Kane's face and I just
love like how rude it is like the alien
doesn't give a [ __ ] it's not like it's
not like
you know like a vampire from the 50s
that would kind of slowly unwind your
window and sneak in a room very very
gracefully it's just you can be eating
dinner and it was just burst out of you
yeah oh yeah
does that the spontaneity and you know
it'll just you know the alien seizure
attacks doesn't care if you've got a gun
doing a flamethrower obviously it don't
like the friends or a book yeah yeah I
totally agree yeah
and that this kind of this is Kane's big
death scene I think it is the big death
of the film I thought I did it really
well oh yeah brilliant absolutely
brilliant
I mean I'm manic picking of the effects
it's very miniscule I obviously I think
this film's brilliant and I loved the
way like they they have his funeral in
space after and I don't know if this was
the first time that it was ever done but
it really likes stuck with me just
seeing his body getting fired off into
space it's very isolated and I loved how
also like no one wants to say anything
at his funeral it just kind of shows on
a human level how isolated each one of
them feels that there's a very much
feeling of loneliness to everyone and
bar two characters they all kind of seem
to dislike one another and just be there
for like the job which I think what you
what which it is which which which it
actually is which is yeah makes it good
just like they have to so if they don't
like your side the difference is to
solve the issue I guess yeah and it's
good because to me it makes them seem
like more in danger because they can't
rely on other people like if you're
getting attacked by the alien no one's
gonna jump in and help you we're just
gonna kind of watch it happen because
they're more worried about themselves
than thinking I mean if they all banded
together they probably could have a good
chance of taking the alien down yeah
yeah they just kind of all hate each
other on some level like don't to say
anything at each of those funerals and
they do kind of break off in a different
group
like as they go searching for the alien
the it's very sort of intense and that
guy goes off looking for the cat by
himself and I really don't know why like
Ridley Scott doesn't do more horror
because he's absolutely masterful with
it like the echoing holes and there's
almost an alien feeling to the
surroundings
um and the tension build up is
incredible when you first see the alien
it like it's near and matched and it
just drops down it's eight foot tall and
you just think like wow and there's not
a sort of screaming or running around or
people getting chased it just paralyzes
people with fear it's sort of like a
nightmare like you're just frozen and
your tracks covered in a nightmare type
of thing yeah yeah yeah um and that's
what I love about alien is like there's
not these long drawn-out chase scenes
where people are running around and
tripping over and stuff like that it's
literally once it sees you that's it
like yeah probably not gonna get out of
it what do you think of the alien design
the first time I saw it I was like super
confused I had no idea I could I
couldn't understand how it worked right
yeah no yeah because always got like the
small amount inside it and you're just
when them things like when I first saw
it I was like how does that work well
then yeah you know when you see it and
mmm and I think it's such a minor thing
but I think the colour I've been sort of
like sleek black is just adds like so
much more to the tension because in them
dark scenes and you know you only see
like sort of like they illuminated parts
of it yeah and everything else is just
in blackness and yeah I think I think I
think the design is I think they really
nailed it I don't think I'm change
anything about it yeah you know it
doesn't kind of evolve throughout the
franchise but I think this one's
probably the best version of it and in
aliens they're sort of more kind of
crappy almost that makes their
it's kind of actually is really
interesting you mention that because I
read that the suits were made different
yeah
the aliens their suits are made of a lot
more like rubber
okay so that the actors could actually
like jump and crawl and like saw that
leap so I think I think that sort of
like maybe where that came from because
I think we want them to be a bit more
animated yes not definitely in aliens is
definitely needs that sort of design for
it because it's an action movie
basically well this is a horror movie um
but I think the design is great I love
how it's got extra fingers and it's a
ribcage is on the other night it's got
like human teeth you can sort of see
within it a monster and and I watched
anihilation yesterday and there's a
section and that way they kind of have a
monster who sort of like a hybrid human
they have certain elements to them and
it's a very terrifying when you sort of
see the human form twisted mmm and I
just love how they've done it in this
film now moving on to the vent scene
what do you think about that I think
those probably that the the one moment
in the film where like you know when I
was must have been like 10 or 11 or
something and you know the cushion came
up yeah I don't need I don't need any of
this I don't need this haunt in my life
yeah all right so you know you watch it
through your fingers but I think is one
of them things that was so it had such
an effect that you can see that see ya
in just literally everything else for
the next like you know 20 years yeah
like coming out of the darkness and then
you know yeah yeah definitely it really
gets your heart racing I don't know if
you played alien isolation but this is
actually as a section way you kind of
relive that scene in the DLC
and it was horrendous like having a
player I'll just I hated my life
I do kind of wish that the alien didn't
do the big hug at the end because it
does take because I watched it with
someone once and it was their first time
seen and they just burst out laughing
when he finally encounters that and but
it was it's just one of those things
you've got to get over I suppose yeah I
love just watch your film with them
again yeah exactly it's perfect use of
darkness really yeah and because Dallas
drops down and he looks at the camera
and you don't think there's a any
anything behind him and just as he turns
around he sees it yeah yeah that's split
second where you see yeah that bit there
is just crazy yeah
it's so good and you discover throughout
the film that the whale incorporate
cooperation want to study the alien mmm
and it's sort of cliche now but I think
it was great at the time obviously I
wasn't there but it does help to explain
Ash's motives throughout the film I love
how it's not just an overblown twist
it's sort of weaved in his part of the
movie and when I was growing up I never
even thought about that side of it like
corporations trying to cap me and you
don't really even have to know is it
yeah I agree and I think just finding
out that ash is an Android kind of over
ways that the fact that a corporation
think they're all expendable and I love
the way where he gets his head knocked
off he's just sort of spewing white milk
everywhere yeah and then from there the
flamethrower gets brought in which is a
huge staple of this franchise like if
you think of Ripley chances are she's
carrying a flamethrower
I mean yeah the classic picture is the
flamethrower one hand and yet the cat
the cat on you in the other arm yeah
definitely em and I love how it gets
introduced here as we get into the final
act so it's a bit stupid that Ripley
goes off looking for the cat it's one of
them innit people doing stupid [ __ ] in
horror movies but I think it's a nice
misdirect because like the the only time
that too
people kind of go together where you
think it would be safer both of them get
killed
mm it's just Ripley on a roam where is
in most horror movies when someone goes
off by themselves they're the one who
gets killed yeah do I do wonder if I
haven't I didn't actually manage to look
into this but I wonder if it was more
into the fact that at that point Ripley
is sort of like you know taking control
yeah just sort of bring like I saw more
caring and feel like a care inside to
the character yeah yeah and that sort of
carries on in aliens when she goes back
for new I suppose mmm which is also
stupid just let the kid die dead in the
next movie anyway
noot does bring something like the
funniest moment of aliens yeah so I
think I think it was definitely worth
her career Beck's when she gets like
thrown around in the RV yeah just like
fuses yeah every time I see that now
yeah it's great um so in there in the
finale
I love how and I've got no idea why they
carry a nuclear bomb on a ship like this
but anyway Ripley sets it off she sort
of runs out realizes it's a bad idea
turns around to stop it but it's too
late and quite a funny bit in this and
intentionally is when she kind of
running back to the the escape ship and
she just flings the cat about sort of
like this mad dash to get away I
remember I like kicking the box and like
dominant and I think there's no way
there's a guy in that but she does
escape but there's one last scare
because the aliens still on board
mmm she starts singing a lucky shot star
and then blasts into space I think it's
like a great triumphant moment and I
love how like the alien tries to climb
back in like a split second
and they're sort of like as it gets
thrown into the the engine there's an
amazing shower scene almost it's just
like such a refreshing like it's like
war getting thrown over you when you've
been tripped like you're dying of thirst
it's just great
what do you think of the movie does it
still get the ending of the film is to
still get you I think yeah I think it's
one of them endings were you know at
that point in the film especially if
you've been paying attention the whole
way through your you you are there with
quickly and you know you're you know
you're screaming in the background yeah
so on that immersion which you know
carries on through the films and into
the isolation game and you know I think
yeah
every day every single time here I think
okay so now kind of you mentioned it
there alien isolation this sort of the
legacy of this film
do you like alien isolation because it's
one of those ones that's got really bad
reviews from like popular game sources
hmm I think he's a lot better than the
other alien games darling that he'll
come out now I never actually completed
it Wow but and that's mainly because I
got massive fan of horror games okay so
you too scared yeah I'm too scared
yeah definitely too scared but just the
premise of a new alien Gil you know I
definitely had to check it out and yeah
I think the the AI quotation marks in it
was really helped with the emotion I
thought the game was great and all
eventually yeah that's one it's one of
my favorite games ever to be honest with
the androids right and I think I think I
don't know I feel like this all just got
overused a little bit okay and well yeah
as far as like a motion goes and like
suspense mm-hmm
I don't think I don't think I've played
a game that matches
that feeling yeah see I really like like
horror games and stealth games um so I
just find it like my perfect and it's an
alien game so it's like my perfect game
ever um annoyed me that it got such like
a low score did surprise me yeah cuz
after colonial Marines I didn't really
want to get burned again so I didn't
play it for like two years and then I
remember I saw it on sale so I just it
was like a seven pound or something so
just so hard it buy it and I was really
blown away by how good it is like the
presentation in that game is incredible
it's so atmospheric and the HS style
like really elevates it the what I like
is there's a lot going on and you're
constantly under pressure yeah you like
especially for the first like six hours
of it you literally like if I [ __ ] up
here and make too loud of a noise then
I'm dead and it just makes you really
feel helpless and getting to kind of
discover a ship that's very like them
not stromal I mean it was the perfect
game and I really can't like a play it
quite often it's all my in-between games
so say like last year I played injustice
2 and then I was waiting for another
game to come out I'd go back to UM alien
isolation in between the way and I'm at
a point now where I'm I'm starting it
again because I'm waiting for god of
water come out and it's just brilliant
replaying it do you find that replaying
it especially with the AI makes it seem
like it is different ruin every time you
go through yeah a hundred percent it's
sort of like I like how it has its it's
familiar but something different is
always gonna happen makes to me it makes
it more realistic
I'm sort of like I can relate to it more
because this is this is a location that
I've walked around for like 17 hours
it's sort of like if it happened at home
I know it I know the ins and outs of my
but you drop a threat into that it
totally changes the environment and the
fact that the alien AI is always
different it massively elevates it I
remember there's a section in it where I
spent about 40 minutes trying to stealth
through the entire thing and the alien
was like on my tail the entire time and
it was really difficult to get through
and then another time I played it was
fine there was literally nothing there
to to get in my way and I just breezed
through it and to me it makes it more
interesting because there's just this
random element all the time yeah I
particularly like the level design yeah
of the game I thought it just yeah
although it was obviously in a spaceship
I've never been on a spaceship but yeah
you know just felt quite fluid yeah like
you know I need to go here and I've
walked a bit and is there not make sense
type of thing and I think yeah I think
the level design was was awesome I think
that was really good
did you play any of the DLC I did not
play any other deals yeah I would say if
you're not like you you kind of just
want an in and out sort of game
definitely get the TLC because it's the
movie so they have two sections from the
movie they have the bit where Dallas is
going through the vents mmm you've got a
go through that um which is horrendous
and I've also got a bit where oh it's
the the end of the game so you've got to
get to the nuclear bomb turn that on and
then head back to the ship and it's a
very very tense moment in it's great
just seeing the locations from the movie
like there's a very famous engine room
an alien and you get to walk through
that in the alien Sorbonne you tale the
entire time and it's very very good it's
really well created um and I think it's
only about two pound now or something so
if you just want I get a quick half an
hour in the game it's definitely worth
picking up yeah that sounds really good
so what did you think of aliens we've
kind of touched on that a bit um do you
like aliens first predator
I really like alien versus Predator
that's really like I know that's a
really bad thing to say but I was like
that was that was like one of the first
DVDs that I bought on my own yeah
and I remember been like a 15 at the
time like a cop in a 50 I can't have
been 15 years old but yeah oh yeah there
you go and I'm like ha ha the system and
and yeah and I think I think maybe
because I was like younger and maybe I
didn't know if some of the things that a
lot of people were complaining about but
as far as like an introduction of the
merging of Alien and Predator I did I
thought it was really well I think it
was really well shot and I think I just
sitting in the scene although a bit
abstract was really cool we've like the
temple ended like the ice yeah and and I
think the guy remembers like the first
of the second fight between like the
predator and the alien yeah awesome like
after he takes his mask off and he like
acids his face yeah I just like when it
been just been a kid in sea and I was
like this is the coolest thing that
seemed I mean obviously now is I think
he's got a bit of a bad breath and I
think a lot of people saw he should have
been done bit different aliens were
superior to was yeah that was awful I
didn't get why Lance Henriksen was in
the first one that kind of really put me
off because I was like I know that guy
and he was in playing Bishop yeah he
just kind of accept any any movie that
lad
but yeah really really has had quite a
long-running legacy I don't know many
films there are now it's like four on
the main series then you've got aliens
first predator and then maybe his first
predator 2 and then you've got the two
prometheus runes so I mean it has had a
massive legacy I would say there's only
like two good for
and in that franchise but you know I
would also argue there's only probably
about four good Star Wars films
I can agree with that I couldn't I can
see that yeah okay so that pretty much
wraps it up um have you got anything you
want to say I think and I think aliens
too is probably better well why did you
pick that where did you pick a lien is
your favorite movie to do what the hell
is wrong with you somewhere I'm waiting
for to get invited back right okay so I
can ramble on some more about alien and
hog hog the mic and but yeah thanks for
getting on the show oh thanks listeners
for checking this out you can subscribe
to my channel I'm doing this podcast
every couple of months and it I'm just
getting a variety of guests on to talk
about their favorite film which also
happens to be my favorite film and so
yeah thanks very much for listening and
we'll see you next time
take care page
you